well you don't have to give up your
favorite comfort foods that you better
here with our cauliflower creations is a
bee-sh are so hot right now it does come
a long way since being that bland boring
better yeah yeah yeah my mother put too
much butter on taste very good right so
you could start with cauliflower rice
and what's the deal with that so
basically it's a great low-carb swap for
everything from rice couscous all those
kinds of greens right all you need to do
pop this into the food processor pulse
it until it gets nice kind of this like
a nice like dizzy nobody even knows it's
not even the kids no one even knows okay
and from this you're gonna make a couple
of recipes exactly so we're gonna do
some cauliflower latkes versus a family
favorite in my home so I've got two cups
of the pulsed cauliflower rice I've just
squeezed out some of that moisture qui
wanted to get these nice and crispy
around and I just put about 1/2 a cup of
some caramelized onion in here we've got
a quarter cup of whole grain bread
crumbs I'm sorry is there a lot of water
in this there is I mean it is a
vegetable there's a lot of them and I
just feel like you know you can get rid
of that and have a nice crispier texture
and we've got some parsley some thyme a
little egg here we're just gonna bind
that all together salt just a touch
mix this bad boy up and you know
traditionally with latkes you pan fry in
like a vat of oil and you smell like
fast through joint for a week after but
I find a nonstick skillet with just a
little bit this is an oil atomizer I
love this let's just take the lid off so
I didn't get this pumped up a little bit
but you get the fan going real strong
yeah you know you're at an airport the
fans are going strong I had to get the
smell out of there exactly so basically
I would just pop these once I got a
little bit of oil in that pan I would
just say you know you want to put a
little bit you can decide how big you
want to do big ones small ones pop this
and get them nice and golden brown on
each side into that nonstick skillet
like that so it's finding them as the
egg is really sticking together you need
a little bit of those bread crumbs just
help to bring it all together right and
as you can see I've topped mine off with
a little bit of fat-free plain Greek
yogurt instead of sour cream and some
unsweetened applesauce as well that's
nice right right yeah that light now
now why is called a flower so darn good
well it's a great great it's high in
fiber obviously we've got some nice
vitamin C some B vitamins and it's part
of that cruciferous vegetable group so
although it does smell a little bit it
does have some mate perhaps some
anti-cancer properties so moderate
cauliflower
all right way lower in calories than
your rice or your potatoes right
substituting here I love that I love
that I love latkes but that's because of
that I do I get so bad go for it I saw
right but now we've got dessert dessert
pizza you probably never thought you
could make dessert with no I did now but
I talked me into it
so we did the rice thing again here
we've got three cups of rice of the
cauliflower rice right again squeeze
that moisture out I have some little bit
of cocoa powder cuz we're gonna do a
chocolate crust chocolate gluten-free so
swapping that traditional crust for a
little bit of a gluten free cauliflower
almond chocolate crust oh that's a touch
of issues yeah egg again we need that
egg to bind some cinnamon some nutmeg
and this is of course some almond flour
I love this because it's gluten free
it's got the fiber protein healthy fats
that's been really gonna keep you
feeling full so you can have like a
slice and maybe not a whole pie in one
sitting right but if you do have the
whole pie you know no one's gonna judge
you it's very healthy for you no judging
you know anything else has to know
exactly that almond that's a good idea
where else gonna put that on low flour
oh my goodness I use it for everything
all my baking because if you want to
make it gluten free you want to add some
fiber some healthy fats to keep you
feeling satiated yeah that's a great
stuff the measuring you the same it's
slightly different but but you know you
don't go fine you might need to add a
little more egg or a little bit more
liquid okay so we basically we're gonna
just flatten this bad fat boy out into a
into a 450 degree oven for 18 to 20
minutes until it gets kind of nice and
crisp and golden you can see you've got
a little bit of branding around sides
there right yeah so I'm just gonna
flatten this guy out okay and this is
the fun part now of course my hands are
gonna be a big ol mess so don't worry
about I got touched you
but you know what we're talking about
you know we're talking about this is
what I like so get the kids involved
right we've got some natural almond
butter when it comes out of the oven you
don't look at that chocolate delicious
this you got this chocolate cauliflower
crust so we've got some yummy almond
butter that's our sauce see when you
have kids and they're picky you
camouflage the food as you do you do
just make it up you go no this is you
make it work you make it work man and I
mean if kids think they're getting pizza
and it's healthy and it's dessert
they're like yeah no don't say healthy
no you don't need to tell them as hell
not stay healthy don't say I don't see
the big H work guys I got as a key they
were right over there you're right
you're right so look at this but this is
it's just like a Natasha was talking
about you know the strawberries yeah
that's all good good stuff one flee with
it you know if you have different fruits
in the house if you got your kids are
picky about what fruits they like just
let them you know let them choose let
them pick and choose and get you know
let them decorate with this one and
what's that your toasted coconut so
crunchy because you want a little
texture in there right yeah I like that
I love it and then I'm just going to
take this spoon here dark chocolate okay
that's good to know
that's right antioxidants right we love
it we love the chocolate so a little
drizzle right on top there
a dance-off you're great you're great
it's so good now let's just say this
very quickly when you are using the
blender yes
you just have to pulse it to get it to
the consistent get the water out of it
what else we need to know I always say
get that water out so squeeze it whether
you put into a cheesecloth or into like
a little fine sieve and just just get a
little pressure because you want to get
nice and crisp I want to get a nice
crisp latkes and yes those pulse don't
just like push go and walk away because
you'll you'll end up with puree okay
they don't want that Abby thank you so
much recipes on Maryland day thank you
got to take a break we'll be right back
everybody
Friday on Maryland Beauty Expert till
done gives you a look at the fast track
favorites to smoother skin then Alexis
Knox pulls off a stunning makeover with
a twist that you can't mix plus music
superstar Carrie Underwood is here
so new product